[Music]
jeremy is in evansville indiana hi
jeremy how are you
i'm good how about you better than i
deserve man what's up
uh just got a quick question want to get
your input uh on whether i should take
advantage of this crazy auto market
right now and sell my current vehicle i
have a truck that i bought brand new um
before i really took upon your uh your
ways and it's gone up actually in this
value or in this market right now as far
as value that's when i have the
opportunity it is and uh i have the
opportunity to sell it um like later
today and i'm just kind of wanting to
see if you think that's a good idea uh
like i said my perspective has changed
on this a lot as far as vehicles go and
uh and losing value
um so i have no debt right now we have
no debt uh really there's no emergency
this would basically just kind of uh
shoot us into baby step four and some
so what will the truck sell for today
um they're
about 38 000
and watch your household income
uh right around
150 to 170 it varies depending on
overtime and things like that
what's the truck what kind of truck is
it
uh one of your favorites it's a 2018
tacoma it's a great truck yeah
okay i love it i absolutely love it like
i said it's the only reason why i would
tell at this point is just what's the
other car we're actually making money
uh
as far as my wife's car
i'm wanting to say i think we uh just
looked into it recently right on 27 000
it's a 2018 toyota camry okay
well here's the thing
you've heard us talk about this
obviously and it's made you think about
this and you can do whatever you want to
do
there's no uh
there's no uh
you're stupid in this discussion okay no
column we check that box
so you can keep it or you can sell it
um and here's why
the car a car is the largest thing all
of us buy just about all of us buy
um
that goes down in value
and so it's a big item and it goes the
wrong way
so they all suck
financially
okay there's not a good one
there's not a good one and we've got an
anomaly in the market right now where it
actually went up in value but that's the
first time in a 100 years that cars have
gone up in value and it won't last okay
it's just till the supply chain gets
straightened out the supply demand curve
evens uh and then it'll it you know
they'll start going down again like a
rock that's where chevy gets that like a
rock so um
this is the the it's just a fact okay so
given that years ago when we first
started teaching people to become baby
steps millionaires we determined that
there are two measures if somebody has
too much car one is if they can't pay
off all their debt not counting their
house in two years well you've already
you're debt-free so that doesn't even
apply to you and the second one george
the second one as far as okay if you buy
a car new no you don't you don't want to
buy a car new unless you're uh what
you've already got this car but if
you're going to call me am i going to
buy a new car i want you to have a
million dollar net worth i didn't ask
you about that oh but if if you don't
want more because they're so big and
they go down in value you don't want
more than half of your annual income
even if everything's paid for
tied up in things going the wrong way
anything with a motor in it yeah
anything with a motor or wheels
totaled up it doesn't need to be more
than half your annual income because you
know let's say in your case you make a
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars a year so if you had a hundred
and ten thousand dollars worth of
vehicles going the wrong way that's
going to weigh you down in your wealth
building right you don't absolutely you
don't you've got about 50 something
thousand and you make 175
a year so yours is not out of line
it's a little high and it's kind of
stinging you because you got new
information the way you're processing
this emotionally but there's no
financial
thing screaming that you need to sell
this truck and you like the truck
i'm personally gonna keep it if it's me
are you just trying to fast track baby
step three right now
uh you know i mean we're pretty much
good on baby step three so it kind of
like just launches fully into baby step
four
and the other part of this too to kind
of throw in the equation is i'm i'm a
police officer so i actually have a
take-home car and that's what i drive 95
of the time so this truck just sits in
the garage and i'm you know normally i
just feel like i'm sitting there
watching it go down in value while i
never use it and so if i did this it'd
be basically to kind of let the market
calm back down and then find a better
deal on a used car that i'd still be
pretty happy with well you can do that
that's not an unwise thing
it's not an unwise thing and so yeah
this is a this is get out while the
getting's good kind of thing i'm with
you exactly and so i i i think that's
you know you're topping out the market
because you know two months from now
it's probably not going to be that way
this is probably this is probably your
one shot at pulling this deal off
and like you said you can go buy
something for half this price
when the market evens back out that is a
really nice truck still
absolutely especially for a driveway
sitter
exactly
you know so yeah i'm with you i think
it's okay but i just want you to
understand it's not the same weight
as if you had 110 000 worth of vehicles
because guys call me up making 250 and
they want to buy a 200 000 lamborghini
and i kick their little butts
because that's just stupid short-term
thinking that's friday night i'm going
to spend all my money that's all that is
as a child and you're not doing that
you're doing the opposite of that so i
wanted to talk through the critical
thinking
of this but i agree with you i think i'd
do what you're doing if i woke up in
your shoes there's no problem with
keeping it though you're not on the
bubble you're not out of line
if you just rethink this and go you know
i just really like this thing i'm gonna
keep it well that's okay
you know but if you wanted to get out
and come up with something six months
from now that was half the price and
still a really nice vehicle this is the
month to do it
because i don't i mean it could last two
more months but i don't think it's gonna
last six more months i'm positive
as positive as i can be about anything
it's not gonna last six more months but
you know george what's that that there's
only two people that can keep their jobs
and be wrong all the time weather
forecasters and economists that's good i
should have chose a different career
path
that's good well and apparently uh
mathematicians in the medical profession
too that's another one but yeah you can
keep their jobs and be wrong all the
time but other than that the rest of us
have to be right most of the time so i'm
actually guessing but i'm looking at
supply demand curves i'm looking at
what's settling out i'm watching these
supply chains smooth out and i'm
watching some of the tsunami following
the pandemic so we shut down the whole
freaking economy that was an earthquake
following an earthquake at sea there's
always a tsunami and then we have this
tsunami hit which is all this labor
disruption the supply chain disruption
the supply demand disruption and so
there's a shortage on everything which
immediately drives the price
artificially up and so all this
hyperinflation you're seeing
you know you can blame joe biden if you
want to but you'd be wrong
i'm not a joe biden fan but he didn't
cause this
pandemic shutdown caused this
and everybody freaking out shutting down
the whole freaking world
uh caused this
and
the economic disruption that we chose
when we chose to quarantine the entire
world that's what caused this
and so if you want to blame something
that's what you blame now there is one
thing you can blame joe biden for on the
prices no doubt about it and that's gas
prices because he keeps tinkering with
all the energy policy and he's screwing
with it and he put opec back in charge
and that's going to drive prices to
double so you got double at your gas
pump that is his fault but the other
economic stuff is not you can try to
blame it on him if you want it may it
may affect fall elections but it's not
his fault it's the tsunami following
this stuff and that's what we're all
experiencing right now and so lumber
prices are through the roof or
whatever whatever you housing prices and
there's a shortage and everybody's
running around buying up everything and
christmas is going to be horrible
because we're not going to be able to
get our little jungle gym thing or
whatever there's a lot of just fear and
people are freaking out about inflation
and i think the best thing you can do
is to do the baby steps get out of that
i was 22 years old in 1982
when carter went out
and
i walked through my teenage years with
gas prices and gas lines
and shortages
and real inflation that went on for a
decade that was double digits wow 10 a
year steady that's inflation to be
afraid of
inflation that spiked temporarily
brought on by this by the supply demand
curve screw up and out there is not
something i'm panicking about but if i
thought these guys were doing monetary
policy that was you know drive inflation
now obviously they're spending money
like they're in congress up there and
and so that's gonna do that's gonna hurt
it too that's gonna slow the recovery
from this down the recovery of this
because you sprint money like that but
that's also not what's causing it
because that money's not been injected
in the economy yet
so it's just the perception of that
that's blowing everybody's mind and then
the poll you politicize it want to argue
about it then you go bananas makes for a
better headline well and you lose all
your critical thinking skills when you
start talking politics so
just melt down
all in the name of what you supposedly
believe
this is the ramsay show